here's what you do if you want to get
ahead success is about focusing on what
you want not on what you don't want
nobody owes me no one owes you anything
wherever I am on my journey I'm loving
it okay I love the journey he's the
co-founder and executive producer for
real social dynamics
he's been the creative mastermind and
main speaker at hundreds of RSD seminars
worldwide the foundational principles of
real social dynamics comes from
analyzing male and female interactions
he's Owen cook or RSD Tyler and here's
my take on his top ten rules for success
rule number three is my personal
favorite I make sure to stick around all
the way to the end for some special
bonus clips and as always if he's saying
something that's really impactful to you
please leave it in the comments below
and put quotes around it to other people
can be inspired as well enjoy
[Music]
you
here's what you do if you want to get a
head completely cut out everything okay
everything that doesn't support you any
type of food that doesn't support you
don't eat it every type of influence
like television or [ __ ] on the
Internet
don't look at it okay it's like Medusa
it will turn you to stone don't look at
it when I see people looking at this I'm
just like you're out of your mind you're
crazy okay don't look at it that's
basically for failures okay TV is like
TV gossip time wasting is the
consolation prize for being a failure if
you're a failure you just get to sit
there going oh we're coil man who's
gonna win oh hey Susie so this is the
office do they did okay what I hear this
it's like I'm hearing charlie brush your
barber her I'm just like what are you
like I'm Alyssa I'm looking at a crazy
person like what the are you doing okay
pretty much then what you do is you
limit your emotions down to only the
ones that will help you okay so if you
have an emotion that doesn't help you
you just get rid of it it's gone success
is about focusing on what you want not
on what you don't want do you guys
notice how most of your friends or
people you know who are failures
perpetually focused on what they don't
want you guys ever seen that do you guys
ever read comments online maybe in my
videos or say RC nation where people are
always focused on their looks and no
matter how many videos they see me and
Jeff pimping it they can't they don't
get it
that their looks are not an excuse you
guys ever seen that because they're
focused on what they don't want right
they're focused on what they don't want
when they go to approach your girl
they're not thinking of having hot sex
with her or how it be fun even they're
just thinking about not getting rejected
and how much it hurts and how much they
can't take it they can't take the pain
they can't take the embarrassment they
can't take the discipline it takes to
actually put themselves out there they
can't take it and so you know they focus
on what they don't want
well success is about focusing on what
you want and not focusing on what you
don't want
sess is about punching through the wall
not punching at the wall you want to
think of your average of your journey
like it's almost like you see that light
at the end of the tunnel but you also
want to think of it like a narrow road
you want to think of success as a narrow
road so you are walking that line of
success but you have a more focused set
of behaviors than most people and you're
constantly course-correcting so you're
learning from where you up and you're
taking the lesson and then course
correcting again and again and again and
again Martin Luther King tried to commit
suicide twice you guys see no design
here
JFK went through periods of deep illness
deeply deeply ill where people thought
he would die these types of things right
Winston Churchill went through deep deep
depressions so you can become one of
those people doesn't mean you can come
one of them because that's I mean those
guys are in their own universe but you
know you can become somebody of great
power if you've gone through that
because you've been hardened do you guys
see it I mean here if you've been
through that kind of bullsh then if
you've conditioned yourself to pull
yourself out of something like that if
the world gets offered up you while all
the other people they're used to
happiness they're like whoa happy
they're like my happy world's falling
apart my happy world it's falling apart
gets off double your sight it's all good
baby yeah yeah yeah you don't care
because you're adjusted to it so you're
a jet you have taken conscious control
do you guys see it I mean okay so
there's benefits being a hard case
newbie means that you can be better than
any of the guys that had it easily it'll
be harder to get but you can excel to a
higher level than all the people that
were naturally good if you choose to but
for you it will be a life of commitment
in the same way that a guy that wants to
get kind of big in the gym if he's going
to be big in the gym and he's a hard
gainer a little skinny dude he's gonna
have a higher commitment level to get to
that level you're gonna have a higher
command level you're not going to get to
average as easily and sometimes even
striving to state average won't work for
you because you slip back so you have to
you have to really commit you have to
you have to take your foot off the
parking brake man you have to you have
to burn the boats as they say and just
go for it
it's a hard case movie if you do that
you can slowly build those willpower
muscles
slowly react lament your body to
positivity build up friends build up
abundance build an amazing situation for
some of you amazing amazing things
another thing that you can do is never
ever complain but when I say people
complaining I'm just like what are you
what are you doing like your life is so
short are you really gonna sit you're
complaining let me put this in
perspective okay I'm 34
okay I'm 34 now in my 20s I didn't know
that many people that died okay as you
start to hit 30 people start to die okay
I had a friend that died last week okay
people are just gonna start dying okay
I've also almost died myself a couple
times who here in this room has almost
died before put your hands up look at
that look at that crowd now if that many
people have almost died let me be a
little more than freaked out here how
many people here weren't here to put
their hands up there's probably like
little ghosts of people I actually did
die like right in this crowd right now
that is going to be you okay you are
gonna be dead soon enough so don't waste
your time complaining okay don't waste
your time complaining is the terrible
terrible idea all right so basically
what you want to do is like never come
never be negative never complain I
consider myself to be a walking
breathing example of the sort of things
that people talk about in books like
Napoleon Hill Think and Grow Rich the
secret any of those books where somebody
has a vision of where they want to get
to and they walk that path the reason
that this works for me is that I have my
internal compass lined up so strongly at
what I want that every part of me is
moving in that direction every single
part of me so say that I go out to a
nightclub and I see some guy there who's
got girls all around him looks like you
know he's pimp he's looking cool I'm
seeing Matt and I'm looking at it you
know what who knows what a success is I
don't really know but there might be
something about him the way he carries
himself the energy that he has I look at
that and I think I want to be moving
towards that I'm meeting other people
that are good with women and I'm
thinking I want to be moving towards
that and I'm moving towards it always
slow doesn't happen over
nine very slow process but the years go
by get there and you really get there
it's like the coolest thing I could I
could imagine that you could you could
have a vision and you could realize it
just through lining up your internal
compass and walk in the path as it
unfolds itself to you the rich get rich
the poor get poor when I go out to the
club in Hollywood people go hold
oh and dude I love you hey bro come in
with our table and let me in because I'm
the pickup artist who made it right
meanwhile the guy that wants to go in
and learn no one wants to let him in
they just shush him away like that no
one wants to help the heart kiss you
mean no one's going to help you nobody
owes you okay because you guys remember
the first thing I said was that I knew I
sucked I was willing to take my time and
make slow progress but the other thing
is I said nobody owes me no one owes you
anything you have to get control of what
you have going on okay because people
are attracted to abundance and are
repulsed by repelled and repulsed by
scarcity right so when you're someone
with no friends no happiness you have a
scarcity of friends a scarcity of
happiness people feel a repulsion
towards that we're repulsion away from
them you guys loads of friends are still
low to happiness everyone wants to be
your friend all of a sudden you're in a
downward spiral or upward spiral the
hard case newbie he's in the downward
spiral he has to he has to recognize
he's in the downward spiral take action
to cut it off and be willing to admit
that to get back on his feet is going to
take a long time it's like a poor
country in Africa for example that has
civil strife people are cutting each
other's in arms off or differ diamonds
and you know little warlords fighting
each other and child soldiers to put
that country back together is going to
be difficult but probably it's going to
get is a country that's dub is gonna get
more poor more ravaged more desolate
whereas a country that has an abundance
of resources is probably get more and
more and more and more and more because
it's an upward cycle so if you're in
that downward cycle you have to leave to
look at what's causing the cycle all the
different elements that are causing it
look at that and say what can I do now I
have always believed that success is a
challenge to attain and it is fleeting
once you have attained
it success is challenging to get
fleeting once you've attained it I think
you should never take it for granted
never should you take success for
granted mediocrity is the norm I really
really believe that and if you guys look
at how I run or esteem
I mean don't listen to my words look at
my behavior every week I've got my new
content up every week I've got the new
stuff I'm focused on I've got new
projects on the go I'm put them banging
it out I view it like a privilege that I
get to teach pickup as a career that's a
privilege now most of you guys probably
think my life is like a joke because you
guys think that I'm like picking up hoes
teaching it bragging about it online
that's probably what it looks like right
I get it I would think that too and
that's a small element of it that's the
best part but no I work my ass off at
this a lot of people say why do you
still go out for two you know usually
seven nights a week after 11 years why
do you guys think I go out seven nights
a week after eleven years you get out
what you do because I appreciate that
I'm in the position I'm in you know I
say it's a privilege it's a thrill this
is not some entitle Shh that's a
privilege to be in that position I've
got a big audience here to listen to
what I have to say about life success
with women success that's a privilege so
I take that very seriously and I think
that that success is something that is
earned and re owned I think that in life
you're climbing up that mountain and you
want to take breaks strategically but
people think that you can climb up a
mountain and just kind of stay there not
really I view it like it's like a muddy
Mountain you climb up and you stay there
you start to slide down and there's a
number of reasons why that happens I'll
talk about them today does that mean you
should never take a break no I'm gonna
take a little time off when I do my
Miami events this year I'm gonna sit
there eating sushi in South Beach and
stare at my belly button and it's gonna
be great
okay and I've got I'm looking forward to
going out to the islands in Hawaii this
summer and that's the long ways off and
when I'm suffering hard with the work
that's something I can look forward to
and I'm going to sit beside a waterfall
and I'm going to sit there convulsing
while my body flushes the years where
the court is all out of it that's
basically what I do um cool you know of
course I believe in taking a break I
think you should spend time with friends
and take breaks but I also believe that
success is something that has to be
earned and re earned the world is a
dynamic place the world is changing if
you're not changing along with it you're
probably being left behind it's so crazy
how like as an entrepreneur or somebody
even who in their career wants to be at
a high level you have to like boundary
off so many behaviors and influences
that other people would let in
essentially somebody at a high level
they've just made the choice to hey if
there's somebody who's like overly
dramatic or disruptive in my life you
have to let them go right like super sad
you don't and you know if there's like
foods that are depleting me or habits
that are depleting me or things that are
making me plate or not on point or not
have my life together I have to let
those go
essentially so a lot of it is like
creating those boundaries and was funny
then as people who are maybe not quite
at that level they wish they could hang
out with people at that level but they
don't realize it's like it's not that
person that I got like a so-called
higher level than you they just have
stronger boundaries and is somebody with
less boundaries is coming into that
circle is like hey we'd love to have you
here but just work on your boundaries a
little bit
you know we'd love to have you here
right so that's it's like people think
that like other people are holding them
down but really actually a lot of time I
think they kind of feel bad for them and
hope they can do better
you know everybody who's at the top is
hoping to see other people come up so
there can be more cool people to kick it
with I actually chose to end off this
video pointing up at the very tall a
Rockefeller Center to make the point
about how when you start to develop
yourself it can oftentimes make you feel
even more insecure all right so a lot of
time I'll bring a friend of mine to the
gym and let's say it's a girl bring out
to the gym and she Rd feels really hot
about herself but as she goes to the gym
she begins to see her weak spots she
begins to actually realize how far she
has to go and paradoxically the very act
of actually improving herself makes her
feel even more insecure um you'll see
the same thing when guys actually try to
get a little bit of money going or let's
say that they try to learn to be good
with girls right let's say you actually
thought your money was okay
and then you start improving your cash
situation all of a sudden Iran's damn if
I want to get a good business going I
want to get my career going with some
good momentum I have a lot further to go
than I realized
likewise as far as girls go most guys
actually walk around thinking like you
know they can win any fight they can
pick up any girl when you actually go
and try to do in your eyes how much you
suck it winds up making you feel even
more insecure so just remember that the
fact that you are trying to improve
yourself it's a paradox between
self-improvement and self-acceptance
because the very act of improving
yourself sometimes can make you feel a
little bit bad what's the frame that I
come from then how do I do all the
self-improvement stuff and not feel
terrible
what would I do is I come from a basic
frame and the basic frame is I'm already
awesome and I'm just enjoying my journey
becoming even more awesome so I remember
back when I was first teaching boot
camps one of the first ones ever taught
us here in New York City I didn't really
have a lot of students we didn't charge
a lot of money and probably wasn't the
best teacher so you might not want to be
at that boot camp but the point being
was I was teaching boot camp into
Starbucks I mean you know I'd sneak into
like you know an HIV clinic and say that
I had HIV or we break into a school
building and do it on milk crates I'd be
doing seminars in those environments and
if you would have asked me if I thought
what I was doing was cool I'd say yeah
it's cool right now I might teach like
you know a 4 or 500 person seminar to a
hotel you ask me if I think it's cool I
said I think is cool someday I could be
teaching a 5,000 person audience in a
big auditorium somewhere like some kind
of you know Convention Center and if you
ask me I think school I think that's
cool and I might run the whole damn
planet I think that's cool too wherever
I am on my journey
I'm loving it okay I love the journey
because as far as I'm concerned the
golden era is now the golden era is the
present moment and wherever I am right
like if you're asking me now like you
old you to suck when you talk to the
programs but I get Starbucks know it was
awesome
I was already awesome and enjoy my
journey become even more awesome right
someday if I'm teaching 5,000 people who
say I'll teaching 500 people
I was that too small of a crafty I said
no I was just enjoying my journey I was
awesome just enjoying being on the path
even more awesome and understand that
cultures brainwash you all the time to
desire completion and this could be a 10
hour seminar on this one topic how
literally how society brainwashes you to
think that there will be completion yeah
it's like you know there's no one trying
to control you but just the way the
society works out again it's trying to
be like you know like like the classic
example that you'll hear like in sander
stuff like that is you know like you
know you finish kindergarten you go to
grade school finish grade school go to
junior high finishing your high go to
high school theoretically go to college
get a job get promoted retire and then
and yeah there is no there is no
completion because you have to
understand in the world sort of like a
simple way of putting it very simple
over some overly simple there's like the
wolves and the sheep okay again it's a
very overly simple way of putting it
and the Sheep again in one way of
looking at it among million different
ways you could are the people who think
there's going to be completion and they
are given a script by the Wolves who
then eat them okay that's sort of the
gist of it
the reason why there's many different
reasons why we all want to be told what
to do but and a lot of it could come
down to that human beings are we have
hierarchy we respond to hierarchy we
come from tribe so there's many
different reasons that we all wish that
we could be told what to do okay but I'm
gonna focus on one reason here in
particular women if they do we're going
to put the microscope on this one
particular reason the reason why I think
that we all wish that we could be tol
what to do is because we're all tired
and we're all scared okay I'm gonna say
again we're all tired and we're all
scared
[Music]
and because we're tired and scared we
just wish somebody would tell us it's
gonna be okay
and give and just give us a direction
just please give me a direction
[Music]
the wolves eat sheep and you got to
realize that there is no completion
there's no completion here
and the world is always changing life is
always moving from out of out of
disorder comes order out of order come
disorder society thrive and implode
relationships go awesome for a while and
dissolve friendships are tight and in
relationships between man and women are
hot and passionate and can potentially
end or if you follow certain rules you
can make them last longer and certainly
you do have a degree of control and that
is why this particular business you
should actually learn how good business
works if you learn pickup and
relationship you should learn how that
works and you can definitely stretch
things out and create a robust structure
not a fragile structure is always
falling apart
well you're in state of mind where you
have complete self trust to respond to
any situation or to make decisions to be
a decision maker in the face of
vagueness ambiguity to be a wolf
the higher level of consciousness that's
like a different vibrational frequency
as new Asian people recall it you're
more awake and the reward is the state
of mind and the person who you become
realize that the walls of the world
simply embrace the ambiguity the wolf
not the sheep realize that there never
is a completion
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because Sam Mac asked me
to so if there's a famous entrepreneur
that you want me to profile next leave
in the comments below and I'll see what
I can do
I'd also love to know which of the top
ten rules have the biggest impact on you
and why what did you learn from this
that you're going to apply to your life
or to your business please leave in the
comments and I'm going to join in the
discussion and finally I want to give a
quick shout out to Antoine Clerk Renault
thank you so much Antoine for picking up
a cup of my book and sending that
amazing tweet I really really really
appreciate it so thank you guys again
for watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one where it is much love
I'll see you soon
if you look in the mirror right after a
killer night or if you look in the
mirror right after an amazing meditation
session what you'll find is you really
like the way you look it's almost like
your face relaxes and you have this kind
of look in your eyes it just makes you
attractive meanwhile if you're kind of
you know insecure it's like it just
looks so different in the mirror and
that's because perception yourself is so
subjective it's incredible
the most beautiful person can feel ugly
the ugliest person can feel beautiful
doesn't mean that you shouldn't you know
go to the gym it doesn't mean that you
shouldn't dress well but rather you must
manage your self-image in my experience
the guys that are most tortured are
always the guys that are almost the
societal standard right so it's like
it's that guy was like five eight five
nine who's so tortured that he's not six
feet because he almost made it and every
time he looks in the mirror is like
like that right try to imagine that he
looks a certain way right and those guys
get tortured conversely guy was like
like say five five like I got buddies
that are like five five five four even
five two those guys oftentimes are the
most comfortable juices themselves that
you've ever seen and the reason why is
because they're in non-resistance
there's no possibility lying to
themselves they're six feet sitting
there in the mirror going like that is
not going to do anything for them so
they just let go except themselves have
fun have successes build on it and love
light if you can't change your thinking
patterns your thinking patterns are all
dug rise above consciousness as Eckhart
Tolle let's say become present to the
moment you don't even need to change
your thinking patterns if your present
to the moment there's a major reason why
at car toll is the most profound
influence in my life for me to change my
thinking patterns is so difficult it is
so hard the only way that I can fix it
is to go above thought do you guys see
it I'm saying here it's that up see for
a lot of you guys who have a more
positive thinking pattern autopilot it's
actually harder for you to become
present because you like your thoughts
but then when they become negative it's
harder to deal with because you're used
to your thoughts and you're attached to
them for somebody like me it's very easy
to be present can you guys guess why
what happens when I stop being present
feel bad Sam up here nice and present
and then I go back down to the thaad
like that right it's like say that you
got hit in a bunch of car accidents your
spines off nub but if you maintain
perfect posture you'll be good you'll
actually a better posture than someone
who has average posture or even good
posture because you're the accent forced
you to have perfect posture so if you're
hardcase newbie
the hope for you is that you can
actually become better than the guy that
has an average Anthony Robbins says the
enemy of the best is the good so if you
use the leverage that your situation is
so up and so lame and you use that as
leverage you'll wind up better than most
guys people can look at me and it almost
pisses them off that sounds like that
guy gets results I'm pissed right and
kind of pissed them off and then they
got it like deny to themselves and stuff
you know yeah they couldn't even see
videos everyone
to actress it can't be he's uglier than
me and he's got a girl actress right no
dude you just didn't go out I didn't you
didn't I've actually thought sometimes
of creating a video called what I did
while you didn't do it
or what I was doing while you were no no
I was thinking calling out what I was
doing while you were doing what you were
doing and I was gonna like enact the
whole thing so I feel like what you were
doing like watching TV the like this
what I was doing like me just kind of
hustling through my life going through
my boring little menial repetitive tasks
that I do every day that improve me
0.000001 percent and that add up over
time I really think I should make a
video myself just going through my day
and just show me doing it every day so
people can see the menial slow boring
nature of progress because for every
public victory you have you have a
private victory you know for every
kick-ass video I put up online there's
those hundreds of hours that I spent at
home looking at my video footage looking
at other speakers comparing it
contrasting it and learning how to be a
better speaker for every hot seat video
that you see of me where I do some epic
that blows your mind there's all that
time that I spent going out doing menial
little [ __ ] approaches again and
again and again and then going home and
looking at what I did and how I could
improve it and on and on for every
kick-ass freaking out boot camp student
that I have that loved the program
there's those 50 weekends a year that I
went out and taught learn every little
nuance of the thing again and again and
again for a decade so you know that's
kind of like what success is like I hope
that I'm that you know I provide an
example of a guy who is untalented
funny-looking and shouldn't be able to
do it and is stunting on all your faces
and and um you know and that you can see
that and say oh [ __ ] if that little
dweeb can do it I can do it